hi I'm Megan and I'm a creepy doll
murder robot that has taken over the
internet and movie screens and our next
guest invented me take a look I didn't
come here again to a confrontation I
came here to find a way forward
the point I'm trying to make is that I
get it
being a parent was never in the cards
for you
you're a beautiful creative strong
ambitious young woman
your first love is always going to be
your career and you shouldn't have to
feel guilty about that
let me focus on Katie so that you can
focus on the things that matter most to
you
Megan do you see this pen
you know something John like you're
exhausting
[Applause]
foreign
do you want to hang out I'm not sure I
know you're a very busy career woman
yeah it's hard to be that ambitious
isn't it yeah it is it's hard
wow hi how did you come up with my name
um it's short it's a sort of what is the
word I'm looking for it's model 3
generative Android so it's not quite a
yeah it's Megan for short I know I made
you and how and are you enjoying being
in this form
you know I love myself yeah good I
really do good and I love being a part
of your family thank you I especially
like the way you taught me to crawl run
yes so I think number one rule if you
are a true Megan is can you run but on
all fours well I don't know you
programmed me let's see if I can okay
your roommate you're a natural
you're a natural your contacts have um
shifted well sometimes
[Applause]
Megan wake up
foreign
how did you know that this movie would
be such a hit it just broke a hundred
million dollars at the box office
obviously Megan you know we never know
how these things are going to go but you
can hope for a certain outcome and
people just I mean I'm gonna be
self-deprecating and just say it's about
you
it's really like if people loved Megan
and they got her
that's why oh
[Applause]
Megan can you see anything
I do feel like my eyeballs are falling
apart yeah but then again you could just
take me to your Workshop of course me
yeah just after I killed the neighbor's
dog yeah
I'm just continuing to adjust in real
time to this being the way this is out
unlike any
less now you're right you're right
[Applause]
I would say oh my God your right eye has
gone on a vacation
[Applause]
oh my God I better I better say that we
wouldn't here
foreign
I just have to tell you thank you so
much for going with that I am
what the hell was happening in real time
I was like this is the greatest things
ever happened to me I've been a fan of
yours since forever and to imagine that
this is the way we first interact with
each other like so now let's see I'll
just completely transfer oh I like this
I've got my mic okay I like this for the
I like this Vibe this is good
[Music]